مشاهدينا اهلا بكم تظاهر فلسطينيون في
الضفه الغربيه وقطاع غزه دعما للاسرى
الاداريين المضربين عن الطعام في السجون
الاسرائيليه منذ 16 يوما ياتي اضراب
الاسرى الاداريين احتجاجا على اعتقالهم
دون توجيه تهم والى اجال غير محدده نتوقف
مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما مدى وجهه الاسباب التي دفعت
الاسرى الاداريين الى المخاطره بحياتهم
والدخول في اضراب عن
الطعام وما هو المطلوب لارغام تلبيب على
التخلي عن سياسه الاسر الاداري المثيره
للجد
يواصل اذا ما
يقارب 140 اسيرا اداريا فلسطينيا لليوم
السادس عشر على التوالي يواصلون اضرابا
مفتوحا عن الطعام احتجاجا على سياسه
الاعتقال الاداري ويطالب الاسرى الاداريون
بوقف سياسه الاعتقال الاداري او تحديدها
بمده لا تتجاوز عاما واحدا يفرج بعدها عن
المعتقل او يقدم للمحاكمه وقد تظاهر
فلسطينيون في الضفه الغربيه وقطاع غزه
دعما للاسرى المضربين عن الطعام منذ ال 2ع
عشرين من الشهر
الماضي اللهم اجعل اسرانا
محرجا اضراب مفتوح عن الطعام يخوضه الاسرى
الاداريون في سجون الاحتلال منذ 16 يوما
بدا بتحريك الشارع الفلسطيني تلك صلاه
الجمعه اقامها مئات الفلسطين
امام خيمه الاعتصام التي اقيمت في مدينه
البيره تلت الصلاه مسيرات في انحاء مختلفه
من الاراضي
الفلسطينيه يخوض الاضراب ما يقارب 140
اسيرا اداريا من اصل نحو 200 اسير فلسطيني
يقبعون في سجون الاحتلال بلا تهم وبلا
محاكمات يوصف الاعتقال الاداري بانه الابن
الشرعي للاحتلال وقد طبق على الشعب
الفلسطيني منذ احتلال الضفه الغربيه وقطاع
غزه عام 7 60 اثر فرض قانون الطوارئ الذي
ورثه عن الانتداب
البريطاني بموجبه يصدر القاده العسكريون
اوامره باعتقال شخص ما بتوصيه من
المخابرات بعد جمع ما يعرف بمواد سريه
الامر يصدر لفتره اقصاها سته اشهر قابله
للتجديد عده مرات يمثل الاسير امام محكمه
عسكريه دون الكشف له او حتى الى محاميه عن
التهم الموجهه اليه لكن الشهور قد تمتد
سنوات الاصعب فيها ان المعتقل وعائلته لا
يعرفان تاريخا للافراج عن الاسير قبل ايام
افرج عن الاسير ابراهيم صويت الذي امضى
خمس سنوات من عمره في الاعتقال الاداري
الاعتقال الاداري لا يمس الاسير نفسه يمس
والده الاسير زوجه الاسير ابن الاسير انا
كان اصعب علي شيء في في تمديد للاعتقال
الاداري عندما تنتهي الست شهور اصعب شيء
عندي كيف بدي ابلغ والدتي وكيف بدي ابلغ
زوجتي وابلغ اهلي انه في ست شهور اخرى
يقول الفلسطينيون ان الاعتقال الاداري
يستهدف النخب السياسيه والمثقفين
والاكاديميين فمن بين المعتقلين الاداريين
تسعه نواب في المجلس التشريعي الاضراب عن
الطعام جاء بعد سلسله من الخطوات
الاحتجاجيه نفذها الاسرى الاداريون بعد ان
ضاقوا ذرعا بسياسه الاعتقال الاداري والتي
لا يرون فيها الا عقابا ضد شخصيات
فلسطينيه تؤرق انشطتها اسرائيل ولا تملك
ادله او تهما ضد م شيرين ابو عقله الجزيره
البيره للمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا
ضيوفنا من رام الله قدوره فارس رئيس نادي
الاسير الفلسطيني ومن تل ابيب اوفير
جندلمان او جندلمان المتحدث باسم رئيس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه ومن لندن صالح حجازي
المتحدث باسم منظمه العفو الدوليه في
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا واذا نرحب
بضيوفنا جميعا ولكن قبل ان نبدا النقاش
نرحب من القدس بضيفنا سامر العيساوي
الاسير الاداري الفلسطيني المحرر ليطلع في
البدايه عن تجربته الشخصيه كاسير اداري
نرحب بك اذا سامر العيساوي ونريد منك في
البدايه ان تحكي لنا قصتك مع الاعتقال
الاداري كيف اعتقلت كم كانت مده اعتقالك
ما هي التهم التي وجهت اليك وما الى
ذلك مساء الخير للجميع بالبدايه انا لم
اكن اسيرا اداريا بل تحررت بصفقه وفاء
الاحرار وحاول الاحتلال معاوله اعتقالي
افراغ الصفقه من مضمونها واعادت للسجن 20
عام كنت محكوم 30 عام امضيت 10 اعوام
واراد اعاده لسجن 20 عام لانني دخلت الضفه
الغربيه مع العلم بان الضفه الغربيه القدس
هي اراضي فلسطينيه اي محتله اراضي الدوله
الفلسطينيه المحتله هذه هي قضيتي مع
الاحتلال ولكن ال اسر الاداري هو يختلف عن
القضيه التي كنت انا موجود
اي خلا من خلالها تم اسري الاسير الاداري
هو داخل السجون هو دون اي تهمه تذكر يقوم
اي بما يسمى جهاز المخابرات الاحتلالي
بجمع معلومات عن الاسير ونحن نتحدث هنا عن
قاد فلسطينيون نواب بالمجلس التشريعي
ذنبهم النواب التشريعي بانهم قام ابناء
الشعب الفلسطيني بانتخابهم لينوب عنه داخل
المجلس التشريعي وهذه التهمه التي تكون
بحقهم هناك اطباء
هناك شيوخ هناك قاده فلسطينيون اكاديميون
فلسطينيون هؤلاء هم شريحه الاسرى
الاداريون داخل سجون الاحتلال الاسير نفسه
لا يعلم التهمه الموجهه اليه من قبل
الاحتلال محامي الدفاع ايضا لا ي ذهبون
الى المحكمه
سمساوي هل تسمعني سامر عيساوي انت جربت
اذا السجن كاسير طبيعي ثم بعد الافراج
عليك اعيد اعتقالك كاسير اداري يعني جربت
التجربتين اسير واسير طبيعي واسير اداري
ايهما الاقصى بين
التجربتين الاقصى الاسير الاداري لان
الاسير الاداري هو هو معتقل
دون نحن لا نعترف لا بالاحتلال لان
الاحتلال باطل واحكامه باطل لا نعترف
بمحاكمه ولكن لنتعامل
بالواقع الاسير التي يصدر يصدر بحقه حكما
هو يكون له ضده لاحه اتهام على مستنده على
امور قام بها هو ل مواجهه الارهاب
الصهيوني الاحتلالي ضد ابناء شعبنا ولكن
الاسير الاداري هو موجود داخل السجن دون
اي سبب يذكر فقط لانه فلسطيني ثابت على
ارضه يرفض ان الهجره من فلسطين هذه هي
تهمه الاسير الاداري نحن نتحدث عن الاسير
الاداري هو يبدا ثلاثه شهور ثم تمدد ثلاثه
اخرى او ست شهور
وتستمد تستمر التمديدات تصل الى بعض
الاحيان 10 سنوات و
13 عام داخل الاعتقال الاداري يعني ليس
هناك سقف زمني الاسر الاداري شكرا لك سامر
العيساوي الاسير الاداري الفلسطيني المحرر
شكرا لك على اطلاعنا على تجربتك الشخصيه
كاسير طبيعي ثم كاسير اداري واتحول الان
الى الاستاذ قدوره فارس اذا موجود كما كان
يشرح لنا الان سامر عيساوي يعني المعتقل
او الاسير الاداري معتقل لا يعرف ما هي
المده التي سيبقى فيها في المعتقل لا يعرف
ما هي الاسباب ما هي التهم الموجهه اليه
هناك الان 140 اسير مضربون عن الطعام في
المعتقلات منذ 16 يوما هل بلغكم اي شيء عن
احوال هؤلاء ال الاسرى عن وضعهم الصحي عن
سقف الاضراب الذي دخلوا
فيه اولا هذا اضراب مفتوح وليس مسكوفا
ومرتبط بنتيجته وهو والنتيجه المرجوه هنا
من الاضراب كسر الاعتقال الاداري ووقف
العمل بهذا القانون العنصري البائد
المتخلف اما عن اوضاعهم فللاسف الشديد
وعلى الرغم من ان مصلحه السجون كانت دخلت
في حوار مع الاسرى الاداريون خلال الاشهر
الماضيه حين اتخذوا موقفا يقضي بمقاطعه
المحاكم العسكريه الصوريه انذاك توصلوا
الى تفاهم بانه بانهم سيشعرون وهذا على
لسان السلطات الاسرائيليه خلال المده
المقبله ان عدد الاسرى الاد سينخفض بشكل
ملحوظ بمعنى ان تجديد الاوامر سيخضع الى
ضوابط وقيود قيود كثيره الامر الذي لم يتم
ولذلك لجا الاسرى الاداريون الى الى خطوه
الاضراب المفتوح عن الطعام ال الذي فعلته
مصلحه السجون خلال الايام ال 16 الماضيه
اجراءات قمعيه عزلت كافه الاسرى ال
المضربين صادرت كل
مقتنياتهم صادرت الملح من غرفهم من ال
اليوم الاول نقل بعضهم الى سجون مدنيه حتى
يكونوا منقطعين عن بقيه زملائهم ورفاقهم
من ال العسرى السياسيين حتى لا يلقوا اي
نوع من الدعم قيدت مصلحه السجون حركه
المحامين في يعني وضعت قيود ثقيله جدا لا
تمكن المحامين من التواصل مع الاسرى الذين
يعني يمتلك المحامي وكاله خاصه من الاسير
بمتابعه قضيته سلسله من الاجرات القمعيه
تعتقد بموجبها السلطات الاسرائيليه ان
بوسعها بهذه الاجراءات المتخلفه الهمجيه
العنصريه ان بوسعها ان تكسر الاضراب رغم
انها لم تنجح في اي من الايام بكسر
الاضراب من خلال سلسله الاجراءات القمعيه
طيب سيد اوفير جندلمان يعني واضح من طريقه
التعامل السلطات الاسرائيليه مع هؤلاء
المعتقلين المضربين كما شرحها لنا الان
استاذ قدوره فارس ان اسرائيل ليست راضيه
على ما يقوم به هؤلاء الاسرى من اضراب غير
محدود السقف زمنيا هل كيف تنظرون انتم في
اسرائيل الى هذا الاضراب تعتبرونه مثلا
عدوانا
عليكم يجب ان اذكر من هؤلاء السجناء كلهم
نشطاء بمنظمات ارهابيه خططوا لارتكاب
عمليات ارهابيه ضد مواطنينا ط ليحاكم
بمنتهى الصراحه خططوا لقتل مدنيين
اس نعم ولكن نحن طبعا نفضل
المحاكمه نعم تفضل اكيد اكيد نحن نفضل
المحاكمه المفتوحه وفقا القانون ولكن
عندما المعلومات تاتي من مصادر سريه طبعا
لا نستطيع كشف النقاب عنها في في المحكمه
ولذلك يوجد الاعتقال الاداري وهذه الوسيله
تمارس ايضا في دول ديمقراطيه اخرى مثل
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا وكندا
واستراليا يعني هذه وسيله مقبوله في الغرب
لمكافحه الارهاب وهذه هي وسيله فعاله جدا
لاعتقال قتله كانوا على وشق ارتكاب عمليات
ارهابيه ليس لا يوجد احد منهم الذي هو
ناشط سياسي سمعت بانه بانه تم نعتهم كانهم
اكاديميين او نشطاء او كذا لا كلهم نشطاء
بمنظمات ارهابيه هم قتلوا حملوا سلاح
واصنعوا عبوات ناسفه من اجل قتل المدني
ولما المعلومات مبنيه على مصادر يريه
مصادر فلسطينيه يريه طبعا لا يمكن كشف
النقاد نقابه عن هويتها لانه يتم قتل
هؤلاء المصادر على الفور نحن نحافظ على
سلامه المصادر ونحافظ على سلامه مواطننا
وعلى فكره هذه المصادر او هؤلاء المصادر
الفلسطينيون ينقذون حياه المواطنين في كلا
طرفي الحدود نحن نكافح الارهاب هنا لا
نكافح فكره سياسيه معينه بل نكافح الارهاب
حفاظا على امن وسلامه مواطننا ط نعم يعني
استاذ قدره فارس اراك تهز راسك لو تريد
ردا باختصار قبل ان انتقل الى صالح حجازي
في
لندن يعني لو كان القضاء العسكريون الذين
يصدرون او يصادقوا على الاوامر الاعتقال
الاداري يسمعوا السيد جندلمان اكيد هم
سيضحك مما يقول يعني اكثر من 70 نائب في
المجلس التشريعي خلال السنوات الماضيه
اعتقلوا والان جميعهم احرار في خارج السجن
يعني كانوا بصنعوا عبوات وكانوا حضروا
لعمليات ضد اسرائيل وفي
وفجاه زال الخطر ولم يعودوا يحضروا عبوات
يعني هذا كلام لا لا اعتقد ان احد في
اسرائيل عامله في الامن او في الجيش يصدق
ما يقوله جندلمان وهو لا يصدق هو يعرف ان
ايه يعني انه لو توفرت معلومات من هذا
النوع كيف لنائب في المجلس التشريعي منتخب
وكيف لمحاضر في جامعه النجاح او في جامعه
بير زيت ان يكون من مصنعي العبوات كيف لك
ان تكون اليوم خطير جدا على امن اسرائيل
وعضو في منظمه تقاتل اسرائيل وفي اليوم
التالي يصدر قرار باطلاق سراحه ليتحول الى
مواطن عادي يعني هذه ادعاءات يفترض ان
يعني الناطقين باسم اسرائيل وقاده اسرائيل
ان يتوقفوا لم يعد هناك مجال ل لم يعد
هناك مجال للكذب نعم ننتقل الى لندن
الاستاذ صالح حجازي انتم كمنظمه دوليه
كاستي انترناشونال كيف تنظرون الى اضراب
هؤلاء الاسرى
الفلسطينيين طبعا اولا الاضراب هو تعبير
عن احتجاج بشكل سلمي ويجب على السلطات
الاسرائيليه ان تحمي المضربين عن الطعام
من اي عقوبه يفرض عليهم وهم
حاليا يفرض عليهم عقوبات منها عدم السماح
برؤيه المحامين عمل عدم الاتصال بال
بالاهل العزل الانفرادي وما شابه اي اولا
خليني اقول بانه الاعتقال الاداري هو احد
اشكال الاعتقال التعسفي و واسرائيل تستخدم
الاعتقال الاداري كنوع من الاعتقال
السياسي فهي فعليا تستهدف هنا الحق في
التعبير عن الراي او الحق في التجمع او ال
الانتماء الى مجموعات معينه سياسيه او
غيره اي حسب اللجنه المعنيه مناهضه
التعذيب وهي لجنه الام المتحده فان
الاعتقال الاداري هو احد اشكال المعامله
السيئه واللا
انسانيه ف منظمه العفو الدوليه كما منظمات
حقوق الانسان الاخرى والامم المتحده تطالب
اسرائيل ب الافراج الفوري عن المعتقلين
الاداريين او توجيه لهم تهم جنائيه معترف
فيها دوليا حسب معايير المحاكمه العا
العادله ال دوليا وقف ممارسه الاعتقال
الاداري بشكل كامل
ليس هناك مبرر وصحيح الاعتقال الاداري
استخدم ضد اكاديميين الان في نواب
برلمانيين موجودين ضمن المعتقلين
الاداريين يعني وفي امثله كثيره واحد
الامثله يعني اعطي عن سالم بادي على سبيل
المثال اعتقل بشهر اثنين من من السنه
الحاليه وهو امين مكتبه في في مدينه
البيره سليم سالم بادي متاسف سالم بادي
وهو حاليا احد المضربين عن الطعام من
معتقل اداريين هو امين امين لمكتبه في في
في في مدينه البيره في الضفه الغربيه
اعتقل اداريا برضه ب بين 2002 و 2008
لاربع سنوات
وشهرين الاعتقال الاداري كما اشرتم برضه
في
التقرير هو لا يمس فقط المعتقل نفسه هو
يمس العائله والمقربين له الاعتقال
الاداري ممكن ن لهذا لذا س نعم لهذا سوف
نسال بعد الفاصل القصير الذي
ناخذه الان ما هو المطلوب لحمل اسرائيل
اذا على وقف سياسه الاسر الاداري ولكن بعد
فاصل قصير فلا تذهبوا
بعيدا مشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم من جديد
الى هذه الحلقه التي تناقش الانتهاكات
الممنهجه ضد الاسرى الاداريين في السجون
الاسرائيليه اتحول الى قدوره فارس الاسرى
اذا يضربون يجازفون بحياتهم هذا اقصى ما
يستطيع المعتقل او الاسير الاداري ان
يفعله السلطه الفلسطينيه برايك ماذا
بوسعها ان تقدم لدعم موقفهم لدفع اسرائيل
على وقف مثل هذه الممارسات
بحقهم يعني دائما هذا الموضوع مثار ومطروح
في كل اللقاءات
الرسميه التي تحدث وكل الوفود الذين ياتوا
الى فلسطين يستمعوا الى موقف فلسطيني واضح
يطالب
دول دولهم بان تتخذ اجراءات تلزم اسرائيل
ان تحترم القانون الدولي والدول التي قال
انها تمارس الاعتقال الاداري هي دول تلتزم
بالقانون الدولي الذي وضع 1000 ضابط
والزام للدوله التي تمارس الاعتقال
الاداري الذي يجب ان تحترمها الامر الذي
لا يتم في ايه في اسرائيل في الامم
المتحده يعني كنا قبل اقل من اسبوعين في
اجتماع خاص لمناقشه الانتهاكات التي يتعرض
لها الاسرى الفلسطينيون ايه وكان في مركز
النقاش مع مجموعه من الخبراء القانونيين
الدوليين كان كانت قضيه ال الاعتقال
الاداري وبالتالي هناك جهود شعبيه حقوقيه
سياسيه دبلوماسيه وستستمر هذه الجهود الى
ان تطوى صفحه هذا القانون المتخلف و وكانت
اسرائيل عام 822 في عهد حكومه مناحم بيجن
قد اوقفت العمل بهذا القانون لتست انف
العمل به في 2/8 19985 بعد عمليه التبادل
يعني اسرائيل تعرف تماما ان هذا القانون
يمثل وصمه عار في جبينها وعليها ان تقلب
صفحه هذا القانون وعلى مثقفيها ومفكريها
ان يطالبوا حكومتهم ان تمس تمسح عن جبينها
هذا العرض طيب السيد اوفير جندلمان اذا
كانت هذه الممارسه وصمه عار على جبين
اسرائيل الان يستغرب كثيرون في العالم ان
تستمر اسرائيل في مثل هذه الممارسه في
القرن ال 21 بحسابات الربح والخساره ماذا
تكسب يعني هل هل هذه الممارسه تاتي بنتائج
اليوم يعني ل لاسرائيل هل من جدوى من
استمرار مثل هذه الممارسات التي تنتهك
حقوق الانسان
الفلسطيني اولا القانون الدولي يقبل
الاعتقال الاداري ولذلك هو يمارس في دول
ديمقراطيه اخرى تحارب الارهاب نحن دوله
قانون دوله مؤسسات دوله ديمقراطيه تحارب
عصبات وتنظيمات ارهابيه لا تحترم القانون
كلنا نعلم ماذا فعلت هذه التنظيمات
الارهابيه هي فجره بساط قتلت مئات الاطفال
ونساء وشيوخ هي تطلق صواريخ على مدننا
بشكل عشوائي ونحن ملتزمون بالقانون عندما
نحارب هذا مره اخرى هذه هي وسيله فعاله
جدا
طبعا حب اداري مفتوح زمنيا لا سقف لهر
العيساوي في البدايه كان يقول انه يعرف ان
س نعتقل اداريا لاكثر من ع
سنوات هل يحدث هذا في العالم اليوم لا لا
هذا طبعا كلام غير مبني على خصا لا
الاعتقال الاداري يجدد كل نفس نصف سنه
طبعا نعم ويجدد الادار يجدد كل نصف سنه
عندما يتضح انه المعتقل يجدد عندما يتضح
بان المعتقل لازال يشكل خطرا على سلامه
الجمهور محدود للتجديد لا يزال يخطط
العمليات الارهابيه من داخل السجن اوفرر
جندلمان هناك عدد محدود هناك عدد محدد
لتجد انتقال الدار يستمر كم مره يستمر كل
كم مره يمكن تجديده في كل نصف سنه في كل
خليني اشرح خليني اشرح كل نصف سنه ينظر
قاض في هذه القضيه وبناء على معلومات
استخباراتيه هو يحدد اذا تم استمرار هذا
الاعتقال ام لا وفي بعض الاحيان يتم اطلاق
سراح هذا المعتقل اذا تعاهد بوقف العمليات
الارهابيه بوقف ضلوعه بتخطيط العمليات
الارهابيه المهمه هي الحفاظ على سلامه
مواطنين انقاذ حياه المدنيين ويجب ان لكن
لكن او جم انت لم تجيب على السؤال لزمات
ارهابيه اوفير انت لم تجب على السؤال هل
هناك عدد مرات محدود بالنسبه للقاضي ام كل
يعني يمكنه بعد كل سته اشهر يجدد وممكن ان
يستمر التجديد لاكثر من عر
سنوات
صحيح لا لا هذا لم يحدث انا فعلا ل لم
اسمع عن فتره اعتقال اداري دامت عر سنوات
ربما ثلاث سنوات ربما سنتين نحن نفضل
المحاكمه المفتوحه لانه اذا شكل هذا
الارهابي هذا ناشط بمنظمه ارهابيه خطرا
على سلامه الجمهور لم من المستحسن اساله
ارساله الى السجن لمده 10 سنوات و 20 سنه
ولكن عندما الادله موجوده فقط بمعلومات
استخباراتيه لا يمكن كشف النقاب عن المصدر
في المحكمه يتم الاعتقال الاداري وهذا
ينقذ حياه المواطنين ونحن فخورون باننا
نكافح الارهاب الفلسطيني اذا توقف الارهاب
الفلسطيني لن يكون هناك اي داعي بالانتقال
الادار ليعم ذ سيد صالح حجازي انتم في
امنستي انترناشونال ما رايكم في استمرار
الاعتقال الاداري في هذا العصر الى اي مدى
يتنافى مع حقوق الانسان في العالم وهل ما
هو المطلوب اليوم انتم كحقوق كمنظمات
حقوقيه ما هو دوركم ما المطلوب لوقف مثل
هذه
الممارسات كما اشرت في السابق يجب
وقف اسرائيل استخدام الاعتقال الاداري
بشكل بشكل فوري وهذه السياسه من منظمه
العفو الدوليه لدول اخرى تستخدم الاعتقال
الاداري او اعتقال يشبه الاعتقال الاداري
وهو اعتقال فعليا غير مبني على اي اسس ل
المحكمه العادله حسب المعايير الدوليه ليس
هناك فعل الذي يحاسب عليه الشخص هناك ادله
سريه هناك منع او ردع وهو ليس مبرر اي
محكمه حسب معاير المحكمه العادله ممكن
فعليا ان ان ان تحمي مصادر المعلومات ممكن
ان تحمي شهود اي وان توفر للشخص حقوق
الانسان هذول الاشخاص ان كانوا اتهوا
ارتكبوا جنايه يجب اتهامهم بتهمه جنائيه
معترف فيها دوليا وتقديمهم المحاكمه ليس
هناك مبرر لاي دوله ان كانت غربيه او غير
غير غربيه ل انها تستخدم هذا النوع من
الاعتقال التعسفي ولانه هو اعتقال تعسفي
يمكنه استخدام للاعتقال السياسي ول القمع
ولغيره ارد هذه النقطه الامم المتحده
ومنظمه العفو الدوليه تقول انه عفوا ما هي
التحركات او الاليات المطلوب تحريكها الان
لوقف هذه
الممارسه نعم بالنسبه لمنظمه العفو
الدوليه احنا وهذا الاضراب هو ليس اضراب
جديدا يعني الاسرى المعتقلين الاداريين
قاموا باضراب عده لعن طعام وكان في 2012
عندما بدا خضر الناد باضراب عن الطعام وثم
لحق لحق ضربه اخرين وثم كان الاضراب العام
للطعام
وجرت لحد الان اطلقت منظمه العفو الدوليه
تقرير في سنه 12 اي اسمه محرومون من
العداله والذي ناقش قضيه الاعتقال الاداري
وطالب اسرائيل بوقف استخدام هذا النوع من
الاعتقال لافراج عن عن المعتقلين
الاداريين او توجيه تهم ال لهم شكرا شكرا
جزيلا لك صالح حجازي المتحدث باسم منظمه
العفو الدوليه في الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا كنت معنا من لندن ونشكر ايضا من
رام الله قدوره فارس رئيس نادي الاسير
الفلسطيني ونشكر ايضا من تل ابيب اوفير
جنتلمان المتحدث باسم رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيليه شكرا لضيوفنا جميعا وبهذا
ناتي مشاهدينا الى نهايه هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في
قراءه جديده لما وراء خبر جديد لكم منا
اطيب المنى والى
اللقاء
ه